Ciao ragazze Questo qui è un tutorial
per un truc per un trucco per occhi
grandi Allora prima con tutto quanto
Allora per usarlo ho usato questo
pennarello che è un pennarello della ehm
della BIC è ottimo sinceramente ho usato
anche Eh questo tombo m buono anche
questo per l'occhio perché potete
appunto scegliere il colore di occhi
perché volete e poi l'ombretto l'ho
lavorato con mi sembra un pennarello
normale che ho sfumato un pochino Poi
per applicare
gli occhi in molti vi consiglio di usare
questo tipo di prodotto glue
clle col insomma sì questa colla Ma che
poi dovrebbe essere spalmata con questo
pennellino in modo per stenderla bene
sull'occhio Quindi io sinceramente
preferisco di gran lunga un prodotto
come questo che è applicabile grazie a
questa palpebra potete appunto metterlo
con con comodità e avere Insomma un
risultato di occhi più grandi penso si
si noti la differenza e quindi sì è un
consiglio insomma per tutte voi è un
trucco veloce che si può fare veramente
per per ogni occasione Ciao ciao a tutti
Allora sono in mega ritardo però questo
video dovevo farlo
Praticamente sì non ho tempo però lo
faccio Insomma perché è veramente troppo
tempo che non che non ne meto uno Fatto
sta che l'illuminazione diciamo è
partita Ho da qualche giorno fa and in
autobus e in autobus ho analizzato le
varie facce delle persone perché se io
non mi so fare i miei fatti i no fatti i
fatti miei in autobus e mi sono accorto
che praticamente il 90% praticamente
delle persone che sta in autobus Ascolta
la musica però non tutti ascoltano in
modo diverso perché sarebbe brutto poi
il mondo non sarebbe vario se tutti
ascoltano la musica in maniera uguale ci
sono delle categorie ci
stanno in ordine quelli normali quelli
che ascoltano la musica in maniera
tranquilla accennano Un po' la parola
Diciamo che quelli proprio che così
Madre Natura ha deciso di farli uscire
sani dal dagli
materni poi ci stanno quelli che forse
un pochino eccedono Ecco incominciano a
eccedere in ambito di movimenti Magari
se ne stanno zitti però sentono così
tanto il ritmo che proprio non gel fanno
a stasse un attimo Fermi cosa che invece
dovrebbero fare però capito Si
appigliano al palo dell'autobus quello
dove dovresti stare a peso così invece
no cominci a fare la lampada sotto
Infatti sì solitamente fanno queste cose
letin americane
[Musica]
poi abbiamo quelli che invece eccedono
ma più in macchina stanno e Eh diciamo
sì Poi se stanno in macchina però se
stai col finestrino abbassato Io sto col
finestrino abbassato io mi giro e ti
vedo che sono quelli lì che si sentono
Maria Callas quelli lì che devono
proprio Si si lanciano nella canzone ma
non capiscono che con le cuffie in testa
non riescono a sentirsi e
automaticamente loro pensano di avere la
voce di Cristina Gilera di Selin Dion
però in verità Diciamo che l'impatto che
fa sulle persone che stanno vicine è è
assolutamente
diverso My heart will my heart will
go uh poi ci stanno quelli che più ti
deprimono quelli lì che sono immobili
Secondo me nemmeno la stanno sentendo la
musica
e sì Non so a volte abbassano lo sguardo
per per per cambiarla Ma niente È
proprio una cosa un po'
triste e infine ci stanno Quelli come me
Quelli come me che sanno di non saper
cantare ma ma sanno di avere cuore sanno
di avercelo il cuore sanno di poterci
mettere qualcosa di poter dare qualcosa
E quindi Cosa fanno si piazzano
solitamente davanti uno specchio o da
soli Però forse lo specchio a volte è
meglio quindi quando stai in bagno te la
piazzi e cominci a recitare
incominci troppe volte vorrei dirti no E
poi ti vedo e tanta forza
[Musica]
non
Things
[Musica]
Allora ragazzi spiegatemelo era così
difficile capire che era un ragno mi
sembra una cosa ovvia quanto voi
dovreste vergognarvi per quello che
avete detto Mi avete bloccato la
crescita Adesso andrò in bagno a
piangere hai vinto il premio Nobel per
miglior nome che si potesse mai trovare
un essere vivente a scaran buad
Congratulazioni in quanto a voi manderò
un video privato nel quale illustrerò
L'Antica dura proprio di di lavorazione
di questi speciali
spaghetti